I thought you know after 911 I I was
really really interested in what made
Middle East romantic and I was
interested in the profiles of the
terrorists and I was interested in the
media's portrayal of the profiles of the
terrace in the idea of Osama bin Laden
and the idea of Muslim radicals and then
I I I was also fascinated by people like
my father or my brother who were
completely outside of that and I've
always written I've always tended to
write from a middle-aged male
perspective already and most of my short
stories always were about men in midlife
so it was sort of natural for me to go
there with with the Middle Easterners
somehow I just thought there had been so
much also written about women of the
Middle East and so much of it was
getting so stereotypical and hysterical
in a sense you know it's a loaded word
with women oops oh but but it really was
i I was so sick of these books coming
out about what Middle Eastern women or
Iranian women and veils cooking spices
in a kitchen and crying all the time it
wasn't my reality and it wasn't a
reality I had observed and I was sick of
it and I had a feeling those books were
just getting published because of the
not without my daughter syndrome in the
US and I just I wanted to look at the
men I thought they're interested story
was interesting in the set of pressures
they dealt with were endlessly
fascinating so I started with my own my
own father and my brother in a way and
expanded from there and now my second
novel will sort of deals more with
terrorists mindset and those other two
my own reality but I think I've always
read books by little aged men I grew up
very much loving I would say the books
and Harold blooms Western Canon for
whatever reason I mean they were
probably because I was Iranian and
female I I gravitated towards the most
traditional literature you know one
could gravitate towards and so I ended
up reading a lot of dead white men
always it was very unpopular in the 90s
particularly the place like Sarah
Lawrence College but I always wanted to
read you know you know the 19th century
British writers and then the American
experimentalists and meta fiction
writers so I and they often write about
themselves so they were writing a lot
about mid minority women so I was always
somewhat in their mindset so I think
that's why as a child I was always
writing about white versions of my
father um it fits and I've had to now
make a conscious effort on the second
novel to write about women but it feels
foreign to me somehow that's that's
fascinating women I think are also more
complicated and more loaded in a way I'm
able to go back to a slightly more blank
palette with men strangely I don't I
don't even know what that means and why
I think that i'll leave that
psychologists I guess
you